it would appear it would appear that
you're the brains of the of the
operation because this [ __ ] rock head
with his [ __ ] up years and his his his
head that's like a an inch to an inch of
cementec it would appear maybe Callens
the brains of the operation and he just
drags along [ __ ] Rocco over you can
be very but but but when I see my guy
here and and and by no means am i
kissing your ass Bernie because I'll
smack the [ __ ] taste out of your
mouth you you won't know what first okay
Brendan you can smack the take it easy
what man can't be confusing or noisy is
it Corona is it my crap just beat my ass
okay you're gonna say something nice
though before that yeah I mean you start
out so positive and now brendan is the
[ __ ] brains of the operation cuz just
wouldn't you think the chipster nails
just what do you think this [ __ ] guy
has has exhausted every avenue of 17
different shows and [ __ ] I mean this
guy's got more [ __ ] shows and then
anyone's ever had he comes up with
another stroke of [ __ ] genius -
[ __ ] bring in the money while you're
sitting there shaving your hair and
watching your chest this guy's crazy
fight clubs okay I know I know I did
sorta my club Rosie's good at planning
you know what it makes sense it's on
brand you're athletic
you're fit okay uh any any [ __ ]
baboon can ride a bike
look Kenny [ __ ] this is a business
man you you Kalin yeah what I'm an
artist
Mauri Mike let me ask you you want to be
part of the thick boy bike club cuz I
can get you in
do you bike bike I'll get your [ __ ] for
your app if you want to go I'll get your
bike but why are you quite to come in
cuz you're afraid yeah why I don't have
the hook up with dr. Rogan so I wasn't
able to get the test you know I know you
guys everybody doctor Rogan you know dr.
Joe Rogan uh yeah a human a man dr.
Trump you know they're they're the ones
that have the access to the tests and I
know you guys have been tested a few
times over here every time I take into a
house
they came to how it's called being
famous yeah we'll let you know how it
feels if you're famous they come to your
house and test you right I got you are
you worried are you worried you have it
right
what's that are you worried that you
have it from the ulcerative colitis hens
the [ __ ] in public goods but I feel
like beating around Kalin anytime I
could avoid that wait a minute that's
fair
oh and you started so sweet and now
you're not there's that there's that
smile again I don't know what's going on
with you now do you think this was an
overreaction to shut down her well how
you feel about this cuz New York is [ __ ]
breath
we're not playing - you're fine oh yeah
I know you guys like to play to your
audience and all that [ __ ] do I think
was an overreaction no I don't think it
was a [ __ ] overreact okay listen Joe
I think that the social distancing has
helped yeah do I think nobody has the
answer
150 150 percent do I think Bryan Callen
has figured enough [ __ ] no do I think
these conspiracy theorists [ __ ]
losers these guys these [ __ ] they're
like [ __ ] what was that documentary
it was last year um a wild wild west yes
yes yes I think these guys are con men
and [ __ ] double talk with their five
G and they're Bill Gates and they're Tom
Hanks they're [ __ ] I agree with you
on that yeah we're with you on that we
agree
nuts thirty seventy life [ __ ] okay in a
couple of years like wearing the [ __ ]
$700 pairs of sneakers you're gonna look
ridiculous you're right you're right
yeah excuse me it's got two kids do you
say how many Judy's 4,200 he'll be 40 in
about two months I'm 37 he'll be so much
younger than everybody will be 40 in two
months at he's worth at he dresses like
a [ __ ] slacker you just like you're
16 I agree I like the hot
like the hottest 16 year old on the
black dude I bring this around you're a
girl she's gonna [ __ ] take that mask
off we'll say that mother out let me
tell you something friend in a couple of
years the [ __ ] $900 sneakers and and
the [ __ ] the skinny jeans nobody's
wearing skinny jeans except for Brendan
Schaub he can't he's got giant legs and
he puts on skinny jeans I agree Jesus
Christ I know
I mean Brendan I mean it and Brian you
you never even imagine being a college
football player did you I'm gonna have
to let a guy mic so I don't really
appreciate this and I'm and Brendan can
attest the fact that I got an arm and I
got like some dodgeball the other days
arm was in bad and I can throw a
football
you're not mad at my spiral or my hands
you're not I was catching balls I was
jumping and Kathakali about it worried
about it we have a kovetz v free area
that we we throw balls at each other's
faces kind of lost your shoulder no no
don't say that Mike because I've
actually been up in my lifting my
shoulders very store because I did
counter bells no stuff my body looks
better if my body is actually and I'm
it's a bit of resting like when you see
it now at 53 people go what that's a
fact so don't be a dick hey Rob you
should come over my house of a full
basketball court you should come over so
I couldn't dunk on your [ __ ] face
Brandon you couldn't dunk on a [ __ ]
[ __ ] baboon
he is a bitter Club he's client he's
very he's lumbering I can dive in I'll
walk your dog crap come on over and get
posted up doc there's no [ __ ] way you
can dunk a basketball court I really I
agree with that he can't do I'll post a
video when I get home post a video on a
10-foot rim of you dunk okay
I don't think okay [ __ ] greased back
here
Fonzie blondie
man your [ __ ] is [ __ ] not being close to
him yeah he is what would you do if you
would you just would you take an open
hand and slap his mouth you have to save
styluses Larry Bird's that's cool Hey
nothing nothing
hey Randy Babylon's give me a compliment
they wrapped you know I watch the other
night I get poked in though you get
poked in that balloon is what you do
yeah you okay dude no hey you know
what's the most underrated movie that
you did that nobody I don't know if
people remember it but the [ __ ] the
shark movie do deep blue thank you
you were so good in that so good in it
no trunk but give me a chance I can talk
I can freestyle now tell me about deep
boots you'll learn about sharks at all
did you study them did you swim with
sharks unbelievable with our real sharks
in it it was a great movie rap when you
run it when you're on a set when you're
in a trailer how many times a week like
when you're shooting the show um what's
the show on the Goldbergs yeah it's cold
yeah two shows I'm on to show doesn't
matter
when you're on your set and your you
have your trailer and everything that's
good how many times we you know really
wanna dance that question I you're just
you're trying to be a dick right now
real question no don't say that because
I'm not I'm not putting dicks in what do
you mean just random dicks in my mouth
like not only all the times rap hookups
Hey Dude please line I'm busy on set
trying to deliver to the American people
with the best of my abilities I don't
have time to just step outside my
sexuality and just go suck I mean cuz
guys dicks a rap how bored are your
[ __ ] kids you know what I get from
rap every once a while I'll get a text
out of nowhere I'll get a text out of
nowhere I've just goes hey let me come
get it
I don't know and he goes come on you're
not doing in with that ass let me I'll
get it good too huh Mike I'm not doing
it just one time
let me hit it hard here peg then it cook
a pig I mean this the guys should I have
to deal with Mike Rappaport I didn't
know where that's my way of checking in
and he knows that and I know that it's
like it's like it's basically like for
normal people like you say what's up you
could when I let him know that I'm gonna
come tear that ass up real nice no prob
that's what he says he knows I'm
thinking about it yeah he goes real nice
thing cuz I'll do your hair hey [ __ ]
know what I had a son I'm trying to eat
with my children I'm getting these texts
from rap I'm like this is a [ __ ]
outrage I will do I'll give you a test
myself I'll come over you take this
please pick a spot on the wall I got it
I got it I got it I gotta make sure
everything's all right I'll take a look
at that [ __ ] balloon ah let me point
you right in the shrimp little with Co
vid I'm riddled with Co bit and I got a
drip and I got a little attitude that's
right - I'm all right Dick's got a call
we love you man
my grandpa for ladies and gentlemen one
of the best an American original I'll
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]